[Music]
maybe a good way to get into this is to
ask why are income distributions
everywhere getting worse and worse
regardless of the nature of the economy
regardless ideology that's just a fact
the second question why do we have
us-versus-them politics and all the pain
and disruption that causes spreading and
spreading across the world so that's
another fact so let's so this is not
based in a personality or some economic
Bewley arity there's a deeper force at
work so it start with some other facts
from 1702 now the rate of change and the
degree of interconnection have both been
going up each feeding the other
exponentially and the demand for
repetition has been going down and nura
curve these curves have been going for
300 years and we're now at a point that
much of the world is already functioning
as in everything changing world where
you must be a change maker to be able to
play in this game and those are skills
that are almost exactly the opposite of
the skills that were appropriate in a
world organized around efficiency and
repetition the old model was you learn a
skill
barbar banking doesn't matter and then
you repeat it for life in workplaces
with walls assembly lines law firms and
that world is basically gone except a
lot of people don't know it yet and in
the world it is all around us the
successful parts of the world you have
to have very different skills you've got
to be able to live in a kaleidoscope
of context that are all changing and it
are connected and you have to be able to
see new patterns and come together in
new teams and work with teams of teams
well this is very complex and it
requires very specific skills and the
world is now increasingly divided by the
new inequality between those that have
the skills and are in the new game of
change and those who are out of it don't
have the skills and this is very bitter
the people who are in the game are
helping one another get better as it
speeds up because that what you do with
teammates you need your teammates to be
really good so that part of the world is
getting better and better at a game that
the other part doesn't see doesn't have
the skills and is being pushed out and
we're telling those people go away we
don't need you it's your fault and by
the way your kids don't have much of a
future so why do we have income
distribution getting worse because
there's a bidding war for the people who
are changemakers who are in the change
game and there's going away demand for
people who don't have those skills
economics 101 why do we have
us-versus-them politics because if you
treat anyone let alone large parts of
humanity in this really terrible way you
can't be a part of society you can't
contribute you are powerless this is
terrible this is so it makes people
profoundly unhappy and of course you
have oi hope yo Ed's we have to tear
down the new inequality and therefore
the income inequality and this
outrageous way of treating a large part
of the population and the key is we have
to help every single human being have
the skills so they can contribute so
they can be
powerful so they are changemakers that's
the heart of it
[Music]